[Music]
hey what's up
hey we did it we did it we did it
episode one
this is the taste buds podcast that's
right oh my god i'm so excited about
this
me too we are excited about this me too
so sal volcano
joe derosa so we came up with the idea
for the show
taste buds we're gonna debate one of
these food things every week
most of the time sometimes we might
stray and do other food related stuff
but we're gonna debate one of these
things every week uh and we're gonna
put a poll up take it to the people yeah
on twitter twitter polls
which we've already done anyway as we're
arguing these things yes
i've had people text me and go is
everything okay
why did you launch seven twitter polls
today
if you see me or him if you see like
multiple polls in in
a certain amount of time it's me and him
arguing
china is right but uh yeah so
so so we what we do is we'll we'll we'll
state
what versus what at the beginning who
you're arguing for who i'm arguing for
right at the beginning we will put a
twitter poll out we will then continue
the debates
and then toward the end at the end we
will check the poll in a segment we're
calling
i think humble pie absolutely because
someone's gonna go down in flames and
has to eat the whole pie at the end and
then at the end we will check the
twitter poll and the twitter poll will
stand this law
yes except maybe and i just thought this
because we're all thinking this as we go
but
maybe just like the greatest battles in
heavyweights history
maybe one day we might want to have a
rematch and see if the cards weren't
going your way maybe
if something's close enough maybe there
could be a you know get revisited maybe
even a rubber match yeah
we are doing traditional
chips ahoy by nabisco versus
the oreo cookie yeah okay so i'm gonna
put up this twitter poll now
and basically joe go ahead you'll be i
already don't like the way you introduce
because you're already throwing shade at
my side
you're already doing it i'm chip i'm
team chips ahoy
all the way you're insane and i'm being
clear i just want to be clear that it is
not
it doesn't mean chocolate chip cookie
it's not the roy the the generic
like chocolate but you can get a
chocolate cookie from 100 different
manufacturers from a bakery
that is an all-time class you did say
you planted things you said
traditional chips ahoy by nabisco which
puts ideas in people's heads
versus the oreo cookie which makes it
sound very mythic
uh you know well i said the oreo because
i can't say versus
oreo cookie oreo cookies chips versus
oreo cookies versus oreo
okay fine well it is what it is there's
just enough crunch
there's just enough give it's a
chocolate chip cookie which
in the realm of cookies is the greatest
kind of cookie
that has ever existed a chocolate chip
don't hit your chips ahoy wagon to the
chocolate chip
your chips wagon because a chocolate
chip
is its own thing a chips ahoy is a
version of it granted i'll give you that
look i'm not even nabisco chips away
people i'm not even against
i don't not like chips ahoy
i will say and if i'm being honest i'm
sorry but i have to be honest it's all i
could be really yeah
good uh i feel the quality of a chips
ahoy has fallen off
as as has most products
uh food products since i was younger
devil dogs aren't the same
candy bars aren't the same cereals
aren't the same even tropicana went from
64 to 59 ounces right underneath our
notes
okay look at that that's an oreo and
that's what it looks like on the package
and that's what it looks like in the box
that's right it's a cookie it's punched
it has the ridges
it has a thing that is exactly you're
getting what you pay for every time
first of all i will say first of all the
crest
imprinted on the cookie has always
depressed me
it looks like something that would hang
over a courthouse or a church or
something
it makes me very sad when i look at it
that is there's nothing fun about it
at all there's nothing fun about this
cookie this cookie looks like it came
from the great depression
it did it didn't change since 1930
that's because it didn't need to oh my
look there's even
milk on the oreos package because people
are like yeah they know it can't stand
by itself
because they go they go i know it's not
a great cookie but look you can eat it
with milk
that's what that is you're crazy not a
[ __ ] thing on that chips ahoy except
a huge bite out of the cookie
cause they know it's so good okay they
know it's so good
they're showing you you have to mesh
this cookie with something else that's
[ __ ] and i'll tell you another thing
i'll tell you another thing i'll go out
on a limb and say i won by a
i don't know what our margins are going
to be but i'm telling you right now it
ain't going to be close
[Music]
you